hello
and welcome to the show
it's me hans kim arena comic just living
my arena lifestyle
uh new digs
uh this is just my new pad just a little
little thing i bought my for myself
after my arena gig
you can see
right over here
it's my telescope
is that the telescope around i got my
orchids
right here
this little little
reward i gave to myself for
murdering in that uh arena of mine of of
ours that we performed in
having a good time
um my name is hans kim
asian comedian recently watched ronnie
chang's new special
amazing really enjoyed the
nerds need to be more respected take
listen to the nerds was pretty nice
remember to guard your privacy
okay i'll guard my privacy
uh sorry i just got a little gotta make
myself a little bigger here
but uh yeah loving uh
my whole
lifestyle that i'm living
in the arena
um
whoa there's like a whole mouse there
just floating in my living room
at the weekend of the house the lighting
looks so good in there thanks man
but uh
let me just move this puppy up
i don't know why there's black bars
around it but
i'm asian
um
ronnie chang had a great special check
it out
um
he said that uh
yeah he said a lot of things in there
um i can't wait you know nowadays our
culture is incapable of making any new
movies or telling any news stories
all we do is make
movies about childhood
child
heroes heroes made for children
characters for children with their
little their little tiny little brains
and that's what we like as a generation
uh all we can do is make uh those movies
based on
uh hero characters that uh are of
interested children
and uh make those movies over and over
again
um so we're sort of stagnant as a
culture which is sad i would love to say
um
so i would like to say that maybe we
could maybe come up with news stories
unfortunately we can't because we have
wealth inequality and we're being
starved out artistically and we don't
know who we are and can't explore
um
our minds without being like oh my
shit's all [ __ ]
there's no hope there's no future and
without hope or future
that it's hard to tell stories and so
we're just stagnating telling children's
stories over and over slightly
differently so my wife and i want to
experience an mmf
i feel like an asian dude would be the
least threatening option i don't really
like the humiliation play thoughts i
think if you're trying to get into a
threesome and you're already looking at
asians the asian dudes you have the
wrong mentality
for that experience it's about letting
go of control and letting go of jealousy
and you're just trying to
assuage your jealousy and your
insecurities by being racist against
asians so i don't know if you want to
fight fire with fire i don't know if you
want to fight your sexual jealousy with
racism
um
but hey if that's where your
relationship is at that's the kind of
fate that racists deserve so
i hope that you do find an asian guy
to play out your weird fantasies
and that your relationship eventually
crumbles under the pressure of your um
insecurities and racism
but yeah i mean if i were you i would
not be looking for a certain race if i
was trying to find a third dude a second
a second dude to [ __ ] my wife or
girlfriend
what i would do instead is i would
try to
[Music]
love my wife and love people in general
and not really be looking for anyone and
anything to [ __ ] her but someone that
you like
and then someone is who is a big part of
your life
to come in and [ __ ] your wife instead of
just
the least manly man
art chafe says say hello to mack hans do
it now
is this how people talk to each other
where you're from
come on do it now
why don't you do it just commanding each
other bossing each other around
i would love to live in a society that's
a little more civilized with a little
more civility and cordiality cordiality
um you know maybe uh give and take and
maybe suggestions and you know you be
you and i'll be me you do you change
things about yourself to command
yourself around commands are not for
others it's for yourself
and everyone can have independence and
thought freedom instead of just trying
to use your freedom to take away
freedoms from others
anyways maybe i should be more
gracious in my responses
the canoe cast asks did you learn
anything from performing in an
arena um
definitely learn something but i mean
it's hard to
put it into words it's hard to verbalize
exactly what i learned
um what i learned
is that
you know
like when you tell your jokes in front
of that kind of audience in front of
that kind of scale and scope it changes
what you think about it
uh um and
and you put your jokes in a new light
it's like what am i actually thinking
and what am i actually feeling and what
do i want to convey what do i want to
say to this city this huge small hamlet
of people
this little village
and uh it uh sort of changes uh what you
think about yourself and how
you're like maybe i should write better
jokes and stuff
hey look i'm in a low resolution house
why does this picture suck so much
um
open image a new tab
but yeah i mean
what else did i learn i learned that uh
people in jacksonville are very very
awesome and there's a lot of them
that's libertarianism
what andrew yang are you all about yang
gang
um
actually andrew yang sent me a twitter
message he said that he showed uh
someone showed my stuff to his team and
that they really liked it so
you could say that i am one of the
capoeiras or capos
in the yang gang you could say i am
in the in the gang for sure i'm like a
consultant or something
um i enjoy the idea of universal basic
income
i think uh
poor people need more money
and if they don't get it they're gonna
be a lot more homeless people and
sadness and robberies at this and rape
and murder
so if you want to get rid of all that
just give poor people more money or we
could invade another country in the
middle east
and give
you know some blue-collar middle-class
white people and whoever wants to
sacrifice their body we can give them
a little little whatever
little stipend
yang is not libertarian your meta house
is sick
look at me i'm in a house
let me be under water
underwater mansion
there's a mansion underwater
this is not a very high resolution image
um but yeah i mean i don't know what
else andrew yang believes in
um
but i
like where his head's at and i like how
he thinks
and i think that uh
he's a he's a good guy overall he's
better than trump
and that kind of mentality he represents
intelligence and figuring things out how
is this a large image
maybe i have to actually click on
and this one has a woman in it
oh that's how you know it's a good image
if if it takes that long to load
so yeah this is just my beautiful life
that i'm living
um
[Music]
should we storm the austin capital
that'll solve everything
um
i mean i think it's good to give money
to poor people
just because
they're the ones that can use it the
most
um
anyways
should we storm asians can swim so this
makes sense asians can swim is that a
thing i mean i guess we're hairless and
we're sleek like dolphins
um
trump is a better president and has a
better policy
what policy
is good
from trump
um
yeah your my girlfriend needs to chill
and put some clothes on is that what
your girlfriend does is put clothes on
oh my boyfriend's here let me put on
some more clothes
said your ugly girlfriend
no i'm sure your girlfriend's great hey
look
who's this guy
do you see this guy
there's a guy right there
oh that's a girl
and there's another girl
right here sitting on the bed this looks
like a photoshop thing
um
i think trump was objectively a terrible
president who ruined the world
he made our voice chaotic and
uh
unified and it made trump or it made
putin it made it easier for him to
do whatever the [ __ ] he wanted because
we were all divided fighting each other
finding out if
uh you know
hydroxychloroquine worked instead of
having a unified voice he just
introduced chaos and selfishness and
uh cruelty to the world
um hans would you still play sc2 or race
did you play as your comedy
you're awesome okay i played as protoss
i don't know anything about the band
tool my green screen was on amazon for
however much money they sell it on
amazon for 30 40 bucks
uh
they're the ones who could use it the
most
poor people are the ones that could use
money the most unfortunately they use it
poorly as opposed to billionaires who
buy yachts
and
you know spend 20 30 000 on champagne
and
i would rather have it go to a poor
person who's gonna buy like a pillow or
like a sleeping bag or something
um
but yeah i mean caviar and all that you
know
[Music]
uh
some [ __ ]
boomer bourgeoisie [ __ ] like that's
a good use of money you think
um
my girlfriend is invisible how did you
afford a van to live in those sprinter
vans are 40k minimum i bought it used on
craigslist for about 12 11k or something
um
and yeah i bought it for 12 11k
[Music]
that's how much i paid for it uh
yeah i mean if you look i'm sure you
could find something cheap
i hope so
i did it and plus if you really want to
live in a van you can live in a minivan
for like a thousand bucks so if you have
the will there is a way sprinter van i
got because i was like well i'm going to
be living in this i don't want to
constantly be upgrading vans i might as
well get a good one now and just take
care of it and turns out i only
used it for like two years so maybe i
could have bought like two new sprinter
van or 12 new sprinter vans in two years
two or three years
my girlfriend is invisible
uh yes trump was hitler like the left
said la mel trump was a horrible idea he
was a joke it's like electing a camel to
be president
uh that's not a good good way to run a
country
and
if you think it was um i'm sorry but uh
that's a sad way to think
i think that a lot of people
are very susceptible to whatever happens
in society or they're like oh whatever
i'm independent i don't really care
who's president and then trump becomes
president they're like he's a good
president i don't know why you guys are
all they just normalize it it's just
they just find a way to
make the world that they're in not so
bad instead of actually changing and
they just change what they think about
it
um but yes i think objectively he was a
horrible president that did horrible
things to the world
and um i don't i think that
i think that's pretty obvious
um
social media and hyperbolic news to that
you're being
put in the less insanity on trump
um i mean trump is pretty insane
uh it's called hans island hello hans
come to hawaii
and do some shows you can stay with us
i would love to stay in hawaii
i would love to
chill out and hang out and do all that
how asian are you i'm as asian as i can
as i am right now i don't know
i don't know how asian you think that is
um
okay how does it feel to be mentioned on
joe rogan's podcast constantly and for
opening for him it feels amazing it
feels like a dream come true you know he
was my hero when i was growing up and
there's a reason i'm
the person i am today for a large party
i was shaped by the p jre so it's crazy
that i got to meet him and hang out with
him
um left is the reason why everyone
is trump is horrible or whatever i don't
think so hey hans zero
my advice for aspiring comedians
is to
constantly be working on it and do
better and
you know do things does it bother you
that some of your comedian friends are
trump supporters yeah it's annoying
it's like oh they're trump supporters
i'm not a trump supporter
well what a divided time we live in what
opposite takes on what the solution to
the world is
do we have
here
isn't that crazy
um
let's go to the opposite and go visit a
homeless shack
open image a new tab
this is what we have
in the greatest country in the world
um
you think you could be successful
already if your name was cons him
more successful
i don't know i think hans kim is a good
name because kim people are like oh
that's a korean thing but him as a last
name is not really a thing hans has your
female activity increased tenfold since
killed tony
yeah i think so
yeah
i mean it's still hard i think a lot of
people
don't want to have sex
because they've been traumatized by our
toxic society
to shriveling and
drying up their [ __ ]
but uh you know i've been around a lot
more women
um and i've been hanging out with a lot
of them and having a good time
but yeah i mean i find this society be
toxic and how much more
uh
you know in tune with that are women
because they have to be around it and
they have to rely on it more and they
have to
you know
be so
see subjected to the yells and whatever
of women or men
uh coming at them for sexual reasons
your friends support trump because he
was a good president what is with kevin
bergman
that check is pretty nice
um i honestly don't think he was a very
good president i think uh he did a lot
of things badly i mean he deregulated
uh corporations and financial
institutions and you know
increased wealth inequality made it
easier for corporations to [ __ ] over
the people and
you know
did a lot of uh things that made rich
people richer and poor people people
do you think you will be more successful
when you realize you are a female
comedian
i mean i already have realized that
so maybe that's what i owe my success to
is
my
femininity
my top fruit might be fuji apples
i like plums
uh my second favorite fruit is teddy
grams
holy [ __ ] it's green screened
it's blue but i guess there's green in
there
um
um
oh i'm doing justin wren's podcast today
i can't wait to have you on the podcast
in today brother i wonder if anyone in
here has any questions about your life
come up some
life challenges etc what are that are
watching right now
feel free to tune in
and ask questions i would love to answer
them hi hans how are you brother was
tony irritated with you because you were
recording too much at the ufc fight
i mean most of the time tony wasn't
paying attention to me
even though i wished he would i was like
a little child
tony tony i voted for gary and joe jorge
but i still think trump was better than
hillary and joe
kevin bergman in the house with a trump
trump talk
um my coworker is from south america and
he said trump made it easier from him
to be in the u.s and now since biden he
almost has to go back
well i'll take your anecdotal evidence
with a grain of salt
i'm sure that uh there's been some uh
immigration stuff that he's been better
at but overall i think trump was worse
for immigration and also it's not just
the policies but the implication the pr
and the uh
the image that he puts out there of us
and that's not a good thing i don't
think trump was good for a national
international image my partner is korean
and her family has been here for 20
years but her parents learned zero
english did your parents learn language
is that normal um
my parents did learn the language
and i don't know if that's normal
i think there was a part in that 23
hours but with edward norton
where
he was like you [ __ ] koreans i didn't
learn the language well did you learn
iroquois did you learn chapawika when
you came here did you continue speaking
american or uh english english
um you know this is supposed to be the
land of the free not the land of the
enforced
english learnings
um but yeah i mean they love their
culture and they're just here because
maybe
things are difficult in south korea
any thoughts on why norm macdonald was
never on jerry um
i think it's because norm
didn't want to go on there
has he never been on
did you learn anything from being
homeless
yeah it influenced me to be the person i
am today i am right now walking around
uh
as a person who has been influenced by
being homeless so
verbalized it um to verbalize what i've
learned
from being homeless is that humans need
very little to survive we don't need
a 40-hour work week to survive we don't
need you know the newest latte or the
newest frappuccino there's very few
things that we need and these few things
are
easy to provide
uh if we work together and we should be
able to provide this to people
and
not coerce them into surviving uh based
on working for us
are you a protest player yes i am
hitting e all day
you must construct additional pylons
always writing in the private jet like
it was like
a cool little thing
um
i uh
so
i have a girlfriend now and
he's great
stavros halkias is very funny
um
but uh she's a very beautiful lady she's
very talented beautiful lady and
she is uh hanging out and having a good
time
oh my gosh
um let's watch something crazy
uh
[Music]
i don't know
this was a good fight
i don't know if i'm gonna get pulled for
playing this
um
[Music]
yeah but i was there for this fight
watching
um
what is your funniest joke
anyways what do you think
the top
three biggest difference between korean
and chinese culture i'm not that
familiar with chinese culture
so i don't know if i can say
um
the top three difference between chinese
and american culture
is that
a korean and american culture is that uh
in korean culture
it's uh
more
um
kinder
um
korean culture is
more
i don't know
americans are more
[ __ ]
i don't want to do this
i don't play cs
um
so yeah i mean
i'm having a good time i've been playing
a lot of katan online which is good and
bad
it's bad because
it takes up so much of my life
and it's good because
it gives me something to do
um
tony and joe are amazing i'm a comedian
and i've been hanging out with comedians
my
whole adult life so
there's like a shorthand that we use and
we all understand the uh insecurities
or
my insecurities as a young burgeoning
comedian
and they uh playfully
uh you know
test my
my insecurities and
make fun of me for
who i am and where i am in life and
they're very aware of who i am i feel
very seen around them they're very
uh kind and aware and nice
in a way that uh most people wouldn't
understand
uh they
handled me
and my um
[Music]
tiny little fragile ego
with very uh with care and uh
kindness and
awareness and you know
whatever
it's like hanging out with comedians
mostly
it's like uh
it's like a comedian hang
and stuff
koreans format more stuff and chinese
topple more of their ancient monuments
and violent revolutions
um
you do cannabis in place of catan do you
have anything booked for may 14th or
15th i'll be in town hoping to catch a
seat
between kt which i'll already be at i'll
be in chicago then
um
why do i only play katan the reason why
i only play katan is because it's
something that i know something that i
enjoy
um i don't really need to play around
and play a bunch of different games um i
like playing one and getting good at it
instead of just flitting around between
many
um i found that i enjoy katan and as
long as it brings me joy i'm gonna
continue to play it
and um
and it's uh
it's something that i enjoy doing and
until it stops bringing me joy then i'm
gonna
keep playing it because i enjoy it and
uh
once i get bored of it i'll go find
another one but i guess it's good to
play around and figure out what else is
good but you know i think there's
something to be said for
specializing and consistency and loyalty
and that's what i have for katan
you know it's like my thing and you know
like i don't need to go running around
being insecure like oh what if i could
be more having more fun at this other
game
no what i do is i get good at having fun
with katan and uh you know playing it a
lot and doing it more and just enjoying
it in a better way instead of just being
like oh i could be having more fun if i
was doing this other game i'd rather
just get good at having fun at this one
game and part of getting good at having
fun is not being insecure and jealous
and just uh trying to go find your
pleasure by
playing different stuff it's like this
is a game i'm playing and this is what
i'm gonna have fun with and let's just
learn how to play because at the end of
the day you're still gonna be sitting
around waiting for someone else to do
something
so i mean
no amount of playing other games is
going to change that so
you know i uh i enjoy just learning how
to enjoy things and
i um
i fully dedicated and devoted myself to
katan
have you ever performed in our kansas
would you consider
coming in the future
yeah as soon as our kansas progresses
into the future
and has legalized prostitution i'll
definitely go to our kansas
yo what did you and patrick david tibet
and company discuss
so
there was a moment when
one of the ufc fighters was like
joe went to the bathroom and then we
were all talking and then it's like yo
can i get a picture with all you guys it
would really like a picture with all you
guys and then i was like yeah let's do
it quick before joe gets back
and then everyone was like
wow you're so funny hans i wish i was as
funny as you even though i'm more
successful than you
i think you're still a good person and
you have boyish good looks and charm
and i would really like to blow you up
on my instagram
just kidding no one said that
but yeah i mean
that was the moment where everyone left
is something i said and then
another thing that i said that was funny
once
during dinner that i constantly think
about besides the many times that i
embarrass myself saying something stupid
is a time when i didn't say something
stupid is when they were all talking
about this couple and they're like do
you think this couple is gonna break up
let's have a bet i bet this couple
breaks up in a certain amount of time
he's like i bet they don't
and then they bet
and then they're like well what if
one of them dies does that count as a
divorce
and then they're like
well no that's not really a divorce and
i was like well what if one of them
kills the other one then does that count
as a divorce they're like
man hans you're so funny and we really
enjoy having you here and
we really want to have you around more
and we love you and respect you
intellectually and physically and
sexually
just kidding no one said that
uh
there's a trial just around taking time
to play katana between digging walls for
the pygmies what a multifaceted dude
have you mooched your way into working
out at jre gym yet i don't think the gre
gym is
um
[Music]
open to me
that's all i'm gonna say
i need to be careful around you [ __ ]
you're gonna ruin my [ __ ] inn with
joe rogan okay
some of this information i don't know if
they want getting out there so i'd
rather ensure my
uh
my membership and desk squad jerry then
reveal tidbits of information to 20
people
at a time
why is there a ladder to your roof so
that i can bathe in the sun you think i
want to be bathing right here in the
[ __ ] grassy dry patch
this place is filthy this is like a rest
but respite from the uh muddy
horribleness that i live in
van life
van life
let's find a van that's like mine
oh it could be a third i could we could
idiot truffle
with this couple this beautiful couple
wow look at me i'm here with these
[ __ ] hipsters
these [ __ ] tryhards
look at these people i'm sure they're
wonderful beautiful people but to me
they look like they are experiencing
life
um
as a
as a in a detached way where they're
like we're doing an awesome thing and
they're just doing awesome things to say
they did it instead of actually because
it's awesome
but maybe that's just my own racism
against the pmc
the msnbc class
of people
you know maybe i just think that they're
detached and not in the moment and
present because they have fedoras
hanging from their wall
and because they look like they don't
know how to experience strong emotions
um
this is actually a nice
van life they got this
weird ass ac up here
looks like it's sort of jerry-rigged
but it looks functional they got this
overhead cabinet hopefully she doesn't
get startled and hit her head on it they
got this overhead cabinet they got this
little door
right here which is nice
uh which i think is on the driver's side
which is
not something that i'm familiar with
they got a little puck light here
um
and that's so far all i can see from
here
i don't really like these uh little
tilings or whatever
but you know it looks better than what i
have
um they got nice
blankets they got a photographer in here
or maybe they set up a tripod they're
like let's look at each other and
pretend we're talking
i'm gonna set up a tripod they got a
nice vent fan up here
that might be the max air pro
um
yeah it looks like a nice they've got
nice handles up here
looks like a nice little thing i wonder
if it it opens up like a like a door
because that's kind of annoying because
then they have to it takes up a lot more
space to open your door
you might hit your head i have mine open
upwards which i think is better because
it's not as
tall it's wider
what is your opinion of brendan schaub
what's the general consensus among
comedians oh my god
um brendan schaub is like a fighter so i
don't want to say too much
um
all i all i'll say is that he's got very
good
uh striking
um
and you know mirko cop
he he marked miracle crow cop and uh
let's just say that i am not at that
level
um
honestly impossible just out of frame
all the feces
there's actually a video of me
dumping out p
that liam sent me i should respond i
don't think i responded
uh
but i think brendan schaub is uh doing
it this is what it looks like to do
comedy and i think people are just not
used to it they want things to be a
finished product but he's working at it
and he's uh dedicated to it and that's
all you can ask
and he's uh working on it and he's
you know doing his best and i think that
if people are this mean to brendan
schaub i think it's like they're they're
not really really kind to the process of
making things and
what that entails
um so i think that's sad i think that we
should uh live in a world where
we encourage uh people who are trying
their best and it's not like he's like
trying to murder people or like hurt
people or [ __ ] things up he's just
trying to make people laugh and
get lots of money doing it but
i think that
this is what the process looks like to
becoming a comedian and a lot of people
um just see him
maybe not do doing that well and they're
like
oh
he's failing huh
and uh you know
it's like uh
hey if if you don't like it you don't
have to watch it but you know like as
long as you're not destroying the planet
um
so
yeah i mean
it's like
is dwight would i like
you know listen to
uh an hour from him right now
[Music]
um
[Music]
maybe not
um
but i think maybe he could have a great
insight
into a lot of [ __ ] and i'm excited to
hear that and listen to him and you know
uh i love his podcast i love his the way
he talks about things i think has a
great mind
i want to know so badly what was cut out
of your set the last kill tony episode i
think it was cut out during the live
uh broadcast but i think it's all up now
i mean i wish they did cut it out
because i bombed a little bit with that
one joke but yeah i mean i think that
it's all up there now because i checked
everyone was talking about it i checked
and i don't think anything was cut out i
have the audio recording so i can go
back and listen to it but
yeah i don't think anything was cut out
i said conservative women i [ __ ] up
that joke about conservative women
because they're like they're just you're
just gonna let men win you're just gonna
let them be the dominant gender that
doesn't sound like a conservative thing
to do is to just let other people beat
you you should always be trying to win
isn't that what conservatives are all
about is winning you're going to be
conservative about letting men be the
dominant gender you should be
conservative about that and try to make
women the dominant gender but
obviously that's being too feminazi and
liberal
hans if you could interview talk to one
person who would it be probably
um
abraham lincoln
interview one person i don't know i like
a lot of people
um
yeah i mean
i think that we live in a world where a
lot of people are
in poverty or suffering from wealth
inequality or sadness and so we're mean
to people
because they're like if i'm hurting why
should this person not be hurting when
he's so bad at
his chosen craft
um
what is a cool image
that i could be standing in front of
um
this is the old studio where's the new
studio
this is this is the new studio oh this
is a good one
open image a new tab is going to be tiny
um but yeah i mean
i think that
we should be
having a good time and relaxing and
enjoying ourselves and
talking about philosophy and all the
different things
so um
what's my favorite city in texas
probably austin texas i have a home
there and joe rogan lets me open for him
there so i would say that's my favorite
city
you look cool in hawaiian shirts
everyone looks cool in hawaiian shirts
uh it's good to be here on the joe rogan
podcast the podcast that's a lot more
famous and popular than mine
i think what's happening in russia is
really sad
alexander carolyn throwing
that was a great picture
this beast of a man
tossing other men around
a man amongst men
but i think it's really sad
that
russia is doing what he does
and that maybe we should be doing
something else
and not doing what russia is doing
um
but yeah i mean
who am i to say
who am i to judge putin maybe putin has
got it figured out
maybe he knows best you know
he probably knows what he's doing
um
i would love to work out i'm starting to
work out a little bit i'm trying to do
good how many times a day you shot
look up scariest wrestlers of all time
monster throwing human beings
yeah look at that this is this is what
putin has on his side right now
alexander carolyn
apparently is how you say it do you
believe in free will
um
i don't think it matters i think it
matters that you behave like you do have
free will whether you do or not because
uh
it's out of our hands
so all we can do is
uh
you know pretend to choose to have
the belief that we do have free will so
that you behave in a way where
um
i think if you believe that
you do have free will then you act in a
better way than if you don't
so
yeah i mean if i believe i have free
wall look i'm changing things oh this
wasn't there before now it's here oh i'm
putting my hands here now i think then
uh it makes
you make better decisions
and it makes you more present and aware
and it puts you in a better headspace so
i hope that i have been designated and
chosen to behave like i have free will
by the alien overlords
um
i think that aliens are
not real i think that uh god is not real
i think that we are our own gods and
that uh what we think of god is actually
just
humanity and other people
and that we should um
we should
really um love each other and love
ourselves and love humanity
and that if we love humanity that we
will be a better person and that we will
figure our [ __ ] out
um is this like in the metaverse i don't
think this is like really his studio i
think this is like a computer computer
image
i'll let you know once i've been inside
and fortunately i have it and also they
have the red uh
the red [ __ ] uh mic holders now they
don't have these long black ones that
come from the top they come from the
bottom
which is better because then you can see
people better um
i have cheap like 30 dollar arm
mic arms
that you get from amazon
um
but yeah you can get a lot of good [ __ ]
on amazon
aliens are deaf real i seen one i'm the
alien
tell us a joke
um
but yeah i mean i think that we are
our own destiny and i think that we are
um
what we've been searching for
we've been looking to the skies but it's
all around us it's the humanity
and the society that we live in the
union that we have as human beings that
is
that feels
like god
if you can tap into that then you'll
believe that that is
then that'll be your higher power we're
looking for a higher power it's around
us uh people around us are a higher
power and we can tap into the group
consciousness
and it is
uh
a very beautiful thing to be able to do
that and it's efficient it's synergistic
like two people
working together is greater than the sum
of its parts than one person working
twice
and i think that
we should forego this pursuit of finding
people
finding a supernatural being and instead
honor each other
and humanity and that'll be
better than a god that doesn't exist but
people that actually do and making sure
that they're
well taken care of and awesome
what's the next time you're coming to
the south
some would say i live in the south
south of texas
this is texas the south
i live in the south i don't live in a
place where i can't legally smoke weed
for no reason if i'm living here i want
that credit i'm in the south baby
i uh can get arrested for traveling with
weed
uh cops are predatory i live in suburban
sprawl i'm doing all the all the legwork
of living in the south i want the credit
of being a southerner now
i live in a place where you can only own
six dildos not seven
so if i'm in that kind of area i need
the credit give me the badge
i'm not allowed to walk hand in hand
with my boyfriend and get gay married
without getting spit on and
you know dragged behind a truck
so yeah i live in the south
florida is a real south
oh yeah everyone says that you know
florida the place where everyone
vacations
and
uh there's a lot of you know
everyone knows that florida is a real
south
doesn't everyone say florida is not the
real south isn't that the opposite of
what people say
people say georgia is a real south
alabama mississippi somewhere with
poverty and
low infrastructure investment as a real
south
um
[Music]
i uh
i think that it's great that uh joe
rogan is uh in austin i mean that's the
reason why i'm here and i think the
awesome thing about joe rogan is that
he's not beholden to any powers he is
independent and he speaks for the people
and if something shitty happens by a
corporation he's gonna call it out he's
not just gonna let it pass
he is
uh
pure
and he is a defender of humans
unlike you know nbc
you know
all those shows on tv all those late
night talk show hosts if they say
something that nbc doesn't like wink
they yank them
they yank and wank them
from the air so
he has an independent
stream of information coming in and i
think that's very important
still depressed tones
yeah
negative emotions isn't something i try
to avoid at all cost if i feel negative
i just feel it i don't try to
will myself out of not feeling negative
um
[Music]
i i don't avoid negative emotions at all
costs
um but yeah i mean some people are like
i feel bad no no i don't feel bad i feel
good i feel good all the time look at me
i'm feeling good
um but yeah i mean what else could we
ever talk about
let me uh try to pull up
something that i wrote
um
[Music]
i uh
i don't think that you should have
emotions towards your job because they
don't have any emotions for you your job
at a corporation or a company is it's
a relationship between a faceless
machine
without any emotion or soul
and you a human being with needs and
requirements and spirit and soul and
then they use that they use people to
fund their
existence
but
you should not be invested in it
emotionally because that'll only be to
your detriment
they don't have any sense of loyalty or
[Music]
sanctity of life all they care about is
profit
so do not
fall in love with your company do not
fall in love with your corporation
instead treat it like the machine and
the tool that it is and use it to
enhance your human life
and do not use your human life to
enhance a company
all the company is good for us to be
used to create beautiful things that the
company
cannot do on its own it only uses people
as a crop to make money
and
you shouldn't
fall in love with this thing
because it provides you food and shelter
but you should use it to your benefit at
any uh at every
every
opportunity
because that's what it's doing to you
and to have any other relationship with
the company is pathetic
and you shouldn't
you know
fall in love with it and do whatever it
tells you to do
um
i'm using my girlfriend as motivation to
get things done because when i don't do
things and then i hang out with her i
feel bad because i haven't done anything
and i feel like i'm wasting time and
then i'm talking to her i'm like
i need to go back home i'm wasting my
time i don't want to
go back and write but i can't because
but if i get everything done
then all right my time with her is
better and i'm not i don't i don't put
extra pressure on that
hangout sesh
to be coming up with bits or anything
i'm just
in the moment with her so
if i get everything done then i can have
a good time with my gf
but if i don't get my things done then
i'm going to be anxious and
feel
bad
and that's just gonna ruin my time with
her and she is not to blame for that and
i'm just making her feel bad so i gotta
get my [ __ ] done when i have time
and if i don't then it's just gonna hurt
someone that i love
and uh that's sad that she would have to
be the victim of that and if my life is
out of control and bad and i don't get
the [ __ ] done that i need to then it
affects the people i love
and i do not want to
hurt uh people that are kind and nice to
me
um so i try not to
um
[Music]
but yeah so that's that's motivation for
me to get my [ __ ] done and that's part
of the reason why i'm uh
doing this
live stream right now
um
[Music]
is so that i can have like a good time
and completely relax and enjoy my time
with my beautiful girlfriend
and uh
i have to drive 40 minutes
i have to get there by 5 15 so i have 20
minutes
so i'll probably call it here
hopefully
it's been good
[Music]
i think that it's important to do this
so i'll continue to do it
[Music]
let me tell you a joke daddy hans i want
your approval well go ahead stop making
jokes so precious
just [ __ ] spit it out there
because people
will be listening if they're listening
and if they're not listening then what
does it matter
what if you're in a situation where your
company is making you depressed i have a
buddy in the marines and he wants out
uh if your company is making you
depressed i would say quit
and
find another company you know i know
it's not easy
but that's how it's supposed to be right
the free market
um
but yeah if your company's making you
depressed that's not ideal a company is
only you
only use for a company is to enhance the
lives of humans and if your life is not
being enhanced by your company then
it's not serving its purpose and you
must leave and find a better one
but obviously i am a
liberal hippie
and i am
purely theorizing
and uh whatever
you just remember doing puzzling for
everyone
dave says never mind then
i hope you don't go to an open mic
because
it'll be brutal
i think that um it's important to um
if you have a joke just to say it
um because you know if the people
listening they'll hear it and if they're
not listening then [ __ ] them they're not
listening
um but yeah i mean
it's never gonna be an ideal condition
for the joke obviously there are things
you can do to enhance the uh recep
receptivity of the joke
but i think overall that you should um
you should i think that uh in your mind
it's very difficult you know
there it's never going to be perfect and
you're always going to be like no my
joke is great it deserves more attention
than this i can't tell it yet
it's like a trap it can always be better
but it can always you should
i mean
doing open mics and doing comedy you're
like
it's
it's you can you can just tell the joke
and
you know
it's uh it's fine like
if people want to hear it
they'll hear it and it's like oh they
were distracted they're not gonna
enjoy it as much and then i tell the
joke and sometimes they enjoy it so
if you have enough situations like that
then you won't be afraid of shitty
joke telling scenarios and settings
um
and you'll just be able to confidently
tell jokes even if you don't think that
people are listening
um
would you tell my joke on kill tony it's
too racist for me to say no i will not
tell anyone's joke on kill tony
i um resent when people ask me that i'm
sure it's told
people say that in good faith or
whatever but
it's like
no i'm not gonna tell your [ __ ] jokes
on kill tony
i'm gonna tell my jokes on kill tony if
you want to tell your jokes on kill tony
go sign up for kill tony i'm not gonna
tell other people's jokes on kill tony
this is i'm not like a [ __ ]
comic from the 50s i'm not accepting
submissions
i'm telling my jokes because i like my
jokes if you like your jokes you should
tell them on kill tony as well
um
uh why do people call cars whips
i don't know
because people are creative
and on that note i'm gonna
call it a day thank you guys so much for
watching and i hope to see you again
and i hope that uh
i was a nice person
i can always be nicer i'm going to be on
justin justin ren's podcast learning how
to be nice
and not a bitter open mic
rat
yelling at people trying to tell jokes
but uh that's been the time
and i love you guys
wait did dave tell his joke
why do people car call cars whips
is that your joke that's just a question
wait a minute did he
i don't think he ever told the joke
good night guys i hope to do this again
soon
subscribe hit the bell for notifications
like
[Music]
comment you'll be high
roller and a low rider at the same time